Just before we get started with today's video,
I want to thank of brilliant for sponsoring it to support biographics and to
learn more about brilliance.
Go to brilliant.org/buyer graphics and sign up for free.
There's also a link in the description below.
Hundreds of years ago,
if you told someone that one's a human beings would fly through the air that
assume you were talking about witchcraft,
and yet in 1904 the Wright brothers flew the first successful airplane.
One decade later in 1914 Jack Parsons was born.
While most boys of his generation was still fascinated by airplanes,
Parsons was already two steps ahead.
He dreamed about building the first rocket ship that would take men to the moon.
Of course,
back then,
this idea,
it was considered a total fantasy and the 1920s and thirties characters like
buck Rogers popularize the idea that humans could explore the expanses of space,
but it was purely science fiction.
Flying an airplane is one thing,
but no man could truly go to the moon and less they had magic powers.
Scientists and engineers from around the world said that the math,
it's simply didn't add up and that mankind would never make it out of the
stratosphere.
For Jeremy Parsons and the opinions of all these experts didn't stop him from
trying to make this dream a reality.
He studied the chemistry necessary to create a liquid rocket fuel that was in
fact strong enough to defy gravity and for good measure,
he practiced a bit of magic.
Yup.
Magic is work would become the basis of NASA as modern day space program,
but his legacy was tarnished by his involvement with the occult.
Instead of being in the limelight of history,
the memory of his accomplishments was pushed aside for years.
This is the story of the original rocket man,
Jack Parsons,
Jack Parsons parents' roof,
Whiteside and Marvel Parsons were originally from wealthy families and
Massachusetts.
They moved to Los Angeles together in the early 19 hundreds in 1914 they gave
birth to the subject of today's video,
marvel Whiteside Parsons when he was very young,
his parents got a divorce and Ruth Whiteside called her son Jack.
Instead.
Roof,
purchased a house on Orange Grove Avenue in Pasadena,
California,
which has the nickname of millionaire male because the streets are lined with
mansions.
Parsons was a bookworm and he enjoyed reading Psyfari and instead of playing
outside and making friends,
he was so fascinated by stories of magic that he wants trying to summon the
devil in his own bedroom.
Parsons wanted to grow up to build a rocket ship so badly he was willing to do
whatever it took even selling his soul to Satan.
Nothing happens,
of course in z later call this experience a magical fiasco and he never
attempted to do it again in junior high.
He did badly in school even though he had a bright minds growing up without a
father Parsons,
he was awkward around other boys and many people considered him to be a feminist
and other boy in his class.
Edward Form in was also bullied for reading science fiction books.
The two became close friends and shared the dream of one day going into space
when they were in high school,
they experimented with fireworks and homemade rockets in the Parsons is
backyards.
He was always trying to figure out methods to make the rockets go higher into
the air.
The backyard was full of large craters made from all of these attempts.
Indeed,
he was so hyper focused on this goal that is grades.
They continued to plumbers Jack Parsons,
his mother,
she sent him to a boarding school called the Brown military academy and the
hopes that this would straighten them out,
but it didn't work.
He was expelled for blowing up on if the dormitory toilets,
Ruth wide sites father,
they'd been supporting that lavish lifestyle.
So when he passed away in 1931 the answer move to a much smaller house.
Parsons was attending college to study physics and chemistry at the time,
but he had to drop out because his family,
he could no longer afford the tuition.
The chemistry classes he took in school were enough for him to find a job as a
chemist at the Hercules powder company,
which specialized in creating gunpowder.
He owns $100 a month,
which is more like $1,760 a month after modern inflation,
and he was also learning much needed information about explosive chemicals.
He married Alan Northrop in 1935 when he was 21 years old.
He tried to save up money for tuition so that he could transfer his credits to
Stanford University and it was simply too expensive.
Jack Carlson,
and he was still really close with that childhood friend.
We mentioned Edward Foreman.
He ends ads,
attended public lectures at local universities to learn from some of the
greatest minds in the aeronautics industry.
So that's a caltech students named Frank Molina,
who introduced them to his thesis advisor,
Theodore von Karman.
He allowed them to have access to the Guggenheim aeronautical,
the Barra tree,
which had been abandoned after the Great Depression.
Once they had access to the state of the art equipment,
they gathered a team of other graduate students at Caltech to help them build
our rocket engine.
As they,
their experiments got bigger and bigger.
They had to move out into the desert to an area known as the devil's dam in
Pasadena.
Their official name was,
the Gal said,
rocket research projects.
All the rounds campus,
they under the nickname the suicide squad.
Because of that,
near death experiences experimenting with explosives.
They succeeded in building a rocket fueled,
assisted take off rockets called Jato.
Soon enough,
the United States staff falls took notice in this rock attention.
The government hired Jack Parsons and does friends in order to create the jet
propulsion laboratory or JPL.
Years later,
this same laboratory would become the foundation of NASA.
Possums made so much money at all of this that he was able to buy a mansion in
Pasadena,
which he named the parsonage.
Hmm.
By Day Jack Parsons.
It seemed to be a man of science and logic that all did.
His friends and family know that he was leading a double life costing magic
spells at night,
and the hopes that the universe would help his dreams come true.
He met the magician,
Alistair Crowley,
and became deeply involved with the occult.
They believed in a belief system called [inaudible] Lima.
The mantra was do what thou wells,
which was a way of manifesting their wants and desires into existence.
Unless Crowley had grown up in a strict Quaker household where his parents
raised him to read the Bible on a daily basis.
Later in life,
he was able to attend to Cambridge University where it became evidence that he
had a genius level Iq.
He wholly rejected the teachings of the Bible and focused instead on secularism.
However,
anything against Christianity was interpreted as being demonic.
Crowley fully embraced this as part of his identity,
calling himself the beast and attempting to summon powerful demons to come to
his aid.
From the time Jack Parsons was experimenting with rockets in his backyard as a
kid,
the idea that man could actually go into space was still a fantasy.
Many people refuse to believe that it could one day be real and while it's hard
for us to imagine now the mere suggestion that man could reach the moon was
considered to be rather simple.
While fell.
Oma has plenty of spooky and paranormal elements to their religion.
Their core belief system was actually not too far away from many new age beliefs
and modern day publications like the secret which calls the concept of the law
of attraction practitioners of the Lima did they in fact believe in magic,
but it wasn't just card tricks and parlor games.
They practiced sex magic,
which is exactly what it sounds like.
They believe that the intense feeling people have while having an orgasm opens
the gate to the universe.
They believed that in that small window of opportunity,
it is possible for a human being to perform a magic spell.
Well,
they really needed to do to perform.
This spell was to focus on their intention while having sex and then wish would
come true because it was put out into the universe.
Jack Parsons became the leader of his own group and they would have huge sex
magic orgies and his mansion in Pasadena.
Not surprisingly,
Parsons,
his wife did not enjoy this sort of lifestyle,
so she left him.
He began to have an affair with his wife's sister,
Sarah Northrop Hollister.
We believed very strongly in the occult,
unlike her sister.
She actually enjoyed participating in these orgies and Jack Parsons was just one
of many men in the group that she would practice sex magic with.
While it may not surprise anyone,
Alistair Crowley was addicted to Saxons,
multiple orgasms in one day.
We're no longer enough to satisfy him.
He experimented with drugs and he eventually became addicted to heroin,
which was his downfall.
As one of Jack Parsons meetings,
he and Sarah Hollister mad say,
science fiction writer named l Ron Hubbard.
If that name sounds familiar to you,
it's because Howard would go on to found the cult of Scientology,
but at this time he was one of the very few saifai writers who were writing in
such detail about the possibility of sending humans into space.
As a hardcore Scifi nerd,
Jack Parsons was thrilled to meet l Ron Hubbard and invited him to join in on
their parties as much as he wants it.
Parsons believed that he could summon a goddess named Babylon.
She has described as being the great mother of the earth and a symbol of
sexually liberated women.
He asked his followers do participate in a project called the Babylon working.
He thought through all of these sex magic rituals,
the scarlet woman would come along to give birth to the moon child.
They believed that this child could be raised to aspire to travel to space
instead of holding onto the comforts of bath if they never actually gave birth
to a real baby because they hoped that this would be more of a symbolic gesture
for future generations of mankind's.
A scarlet woman was a symbol of free love throughout the world so people could
have sex outside of marriage more openly.
In a way,
you could actually say that this spell actually worked just a few years later.
The United States entered the space race in the entire world's turned on their
televisions to watch the first steps onto the moon in the 1960s the hippies then
spread the free love movement that Parsons had hoped for.
Maybe just maybe all of that sex magic actually ended up working
after discovering his ties to the occult in the late Forties Jack Parsons was
fired from his job at the Jet Propulsion Laboratory.
Since he was down on his luck.
L Ron Hubbard asked Jack Parsons if he would be interested in partnering in a
Boot Business in Florida.
Parsons gave hobbits $20,000 to start the business and Sarah Lester asked if she
could go to after stealing his girlfriends and robbing him,
blind Parsons realized that he'd made a terrible mistake by trusting him.
At this point,
l Ron Hubbard did create a successful boating business,
but he never paid the money back.
Jack Parsons out to go to court to get his $20,000.
Years later,
I'll,
Ron Hubbard would become the founder of his own religion called Scientology and
he used this boat business to create a sea org.
He borrowed much of the same principles taught by Alistair Crowley and Jack
Parsons about setting intentions and being the best person you can be.
He also mixed in his own fictional ideas made up in his science fiction novels,
even though Sarah Hollister left Jack Parsons to Mary l Ron Hubbard,
there were plenty of other women in the group who practically worshiped him.
He mass an actress and artists named Marjorie Cameron.
Just like all of his other intentions.
He had put his ideas about an elements or woman out into the universe,
so when he met her he believed that they were soulmates.
They were so intensely attracted to one another when they first met that they
spent two weeks straight making love in his bedroom.
He married Cameron in 1946 Marjorie Cameron was more than a tad bit eccentric.
She claims that she had visions of the coming apocalypse and she created artwork
about how a cults beliefs that would later become popular during the beat
generation.
The 1950s was the beginning of the McCarthy era where the FBI was investigating
anyone under suspicion of having ties to the communist party.
They began to investigate Jack Parsons due to the fact that he took documents
saying from his new employer aircraft company,
they suspected that he may be supplying the USS all with these documents about
rocket engines.
After learning,
he was under investigation.
Jack Parsons voluntarily showed up at the FBI offices in Los Angeles to explain
that he took the documents home because he wanted to give examples of his past
work to apply to a job in Israel.
The FBI at this point thought that he could actually be a spy for the Israeli
government.
He was fired from the Hughes Aircraft Company and this was enough to blacklist
him from ever guessing another aeronautical drop again.
Declassified documents reveal that the FBI had been following Jack Parsons
movements since 1948 because it is a cult ties to us to Crowley.
They believe that this was a subversive group and it's considered to be
dangerous.
They were simply waiting for a moment where he might've slept up in 1951 in
Parsons career was over and his marriage to Marjorie Cameron was falling apart,
so they separated.
Jack Parsons was no longer ranking in huge paychecks.
He occasionally works as an explosives consultants on the sets of Hollywood
action films,
but these gigs were few and far between he and to work the night shift at a gas
station and he rented out the spare rooms in his house for extra income.
In June of 1952 Parsons received an order from a film set to create several
explosives for a movie.
They asked him to hurry because they were running on a tight schedule.
One of his tenants jokes,
be careful or your blow us all up.
Parsons responded with a chocolate and said that everything would be fine.
An hour later,
the lab exploded.
He was still alive,
but half of his face had been blown off from an explosion.
It was rushed to the hospital,
but he died from his injuries.
Just 37 years old.
His official cause of death had been ruled as an accidents,
but many elements of the explosion ops around it,
a mystery.
He had so many years of mixing chemicals and creating bombs.
People find it hard to believe that Jack Parsons could have made such a careless
mistake,
something that maybe it was feeling so low that he wanted to kill himself,
but if Parsons intention truly wants to commit suicide,
he would have known how to build a bomb that would have killed himself instantly
instead of suffering in the hospital.
Some people speculate that someone wanted him dead ends.
They snuck into his lab to tamper with this chemicals.
The idea that he was assassinated by the government is a conspiracy,
but it certainly does make a lot of sense.
It seems almost too convenient that Jack Parsons blew himself up at the start of
the Cold War.
He knew plenty of government secrets about that fledgling space program and he
was already showing signs of wanting to flee the country.
Parsons truly was a genius capable of building a bigger and better Rawkus than
the ones created by the u s government,
and they may have feared that he would sell his services to the USSR.
The fact that Jack Parsons credited his work with the occult for a success in
rocket science was an embarrassment the rest of the aeronautical community.
If the public knew about this,
it would completely ruin the credibility of the government's attempts to build a
space program,
but they were already having a hard time raising taxpayer dollars without some
guy chatting about sex magic.
Sadly,
the program and is a lot more credibility you want to see was out of the picture
after his death.
NASA would name one if the craters on the moon after Jack Parsons only.
It was on the dark side.
This is very much how they felt about his contribution to rocket science,
but they wanted to give credit where credit is due,
but many wanted to keep his memory out of the limelight while he was alive.
Jack Parsons,
his ultimate goal was to have his rocket experiments succeed not just for
himself,
but for future generations.
He wanted the whole world to look to the stars and know that it could be a
reality and not just some fantasy written about in a Scifi novel,
whether you believe in the supernatural Nazi in a way past and sex magic spell
is actually worked because all of his intentions that he sat out into the
universe eventually came true.
Tragically,
he did not live long enough to see NASA send demand to the moon,
but if he was watching from across the universe,
it would surely be proud and if you want to learn a bit about the real stuff
that Parsons was interested in,
a great way to do that is through brilliance.
We talked a lot about rocket science in today's video and while this is
certainly a complex subject,
it is one that brilliant make really easy to get to grips with.
The way brilliant works is through something called active learning and it's
really super effective.
Basically what this means is that you're not spending time reading about how
something works,
looking at complex equations,
etc. Basically going over it again and again and again until it gets in your
head.
For me often.
That's something that gets just really frustrating.
I know a lot of people feel the same way.
Taking rocket physics as an example,
rather than showing you something really complex and explaining it,
it all starts with something super simple.
You just have to solve a puzzle related to the topic.
It's great to see how you do a few of these puzzles and just a few minutes later
you find yourself saying,
oh,
so that's what the side of the equation works.
It's very cool and as someone without a background in science,
I pretty much started off thinking,
yeah,
guys in not getting to be able to explain that equation to me,
but just a few interactive puzzles,
lace.
I'm like,
Oh,
well now I get it.
That's pretty cool.
It really is just like that.
It's kind of a weird way to describe the process.
I know,
but that's how it works.
It's really interesting how the information and has your head through this way
of active learning.
It's a great way to learn and to support biographics and learn more about
brilliance.
Please go to brilliant.org/biographics and sign up for free.
And also the first 200 people that go through that link,
we'll get 20% off the annual premium subscription.
So it was always,
thank you so much for watching this video.
Do subscribe for more,
do check out brilliance,
and as always,
thank you for watching.